what's up internet this is dr john
dolone with ramsey network
today we are taking emails we are
talking about
loneliness anxiety and
anger we're all in it one big important
thing a couple people have been emailing
me about the books here
on my shelf this isn't my shelf this is
a
corner of a studio space in this rad
big ecosystem over here at ramsey
solutions i've never read any of these
books i don't even know what books they
are
they're probably good probably all right
so
first email up is from joe by the way
this is paper for you millennials i've
printed off the internets
and it comes out this way it's awesome
okay hi john what's up
good to see you hope you're doing good
joe thank you so much for your efforts
in providing us with advice on our
well-being
you got it um i'm 26 single and living
by myself
because i have a health condition that
may possibly make cover 19 worse i've
been working from home
and socially distancing from everyone
except my parents since march
and now local hospitals are filling up
with covet patients
i'm in good health in every way
including mental health and finances
but i wonder if this is unhealthy to be
as disconnected from
friends as i have i feel like the good
relationships i had before
are weakening do you have an opinion on
whether this situation is detrimental to
my health to the point where i should
handle this situation
differently thank you so much joe
awesome email thank you joe
congratulations on being
mentally well financially well and
physically well
taking care of yourself knowing your
health
your situation in your community and do
what you need to do to keep yourself
safe
high five to you for having a brain and
using it for god's sakes all right so
your big question here is this
is it okay to be lonely you've been by
yourself for a few months
now so you're recognizing that your
relationships are weakening they're
starting to fray
your buddies it was cool to call each
other the first month and talk and laugh
and we're all sending back memes and now
it's july
the calls aren't coming anymore people
are starting to go
out but you're still staying at home
you're hanging out with your mom and dad
and that's only so cool for so long
and your question is is this detrimental
to your health
short and long term the answer
unfortunately
and fortunately is yes loneliness
will kill you not having friends not
having a community
will slowly over time wear you out
psychologically
spiritually emotionally and physically
we were designed to have people in our
lives
in this season that's going to look
different for everybody
so here's a couple things i'm going to
recommend you joe
do today and anyone else watching this
on the tubes
y'all can do this too number one get
back into a regular rotation
of calling your friends call them even
when you don't feel like it
even if this is gonna sound kind of
gnarly you got to put it on the calendar
call a buddy call somebody call your old
roommates call your friends from work
call somebody that you just met i don't
care who it is make it a regular habit
of being in connection with one another
talk to people number two consider
outside back porch front yard get
togethers
my neighborhood has had a couple of
outdoor cookouts on the lawn where we're
all socially distanced
and we're all eating real good and we're
all back to laughing at each
other carrying on seeing how each
other's doing
singing songs playing guitar just being
loud and goofy
it's what we're designed to do i've also
had a couple of buddies come over
they sit on my back porch after my kids
are asleep we're far enough away from
each other where we're safe
but we're still hanging out every friday
morning
i drive 30 minutes out of the way and i
go meet with one of my good friends and
mentors
a former pastor of mine who's now one of
my closest friends we meet on his back
porch for coffee
before the world wakes up and i have to
have that
i've got to have it so i'm going to
recommend you do that too find ways
where you can get in touch with people
in person outside where it's safe or if
you can do it
safely inside or wear masks or whatever
you need to do
but find ways where you can connect with
people in person and number three
this really wraps up the first two make
it a priority
because what we're gonna find is come
august september
december next may
when the sun comes up and somebody
somewhere gets on some sort of
high tall tree and announces covid's
over
the lockdown's over you're free to run
about the yard
we're not going to know what to do and
we're going to have a whole host of
psychiatric
and psychological and emotional
challenges because we were so
so lonely so make it a priority
you've got this joe keep going connect
with other people
everyone do the internet's thing buttons
push subscribe subscribe what else are
you doing subscribe
and if you've got questions for me email
me at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com talk to you soon
stay in school don't do drugs
peace out